im land der unzähligen tempel ragt einer
heraus im wahrsten sinne des wortes
putin den elementen trotzend von buddha
beschützt
mit seiner geste besänftigt der butter
den regen hält den sturm auf er hilft
uns gegen die wellen und den wind
der tempel hat die hilfe nötig vor ein
paar jahren noch lag mitten im dorf
jetzt liegt er mitten im wasser der
meeresspiegel steigt der boden sinkt ab
sie bauen dagegen an gegen den
klimawandel und seine folgen
denn dass das wasser sich ihrem tempel
holt ist schwer zu ertragen
also packen alle mit an wollen nicht
weichen
wir bauen einen neuen tempel komplett
aus holz dann ist er leichter wir bauen
ihn direkt neben dem alten der versinkt
immer weiter der boden codiert und der
tempel ist zu schwer die menschen im
dorf sind schon war flog nur der tempel
ist geblieben vom wasser umgeben
häuser auf dämmen häuser auf stelzen
immer höher haben sie gebaut immer
weiter landeinwärts ist die siedlung
gezogen
pisano kings armut ist der dorfvorsteher
so wie sein vater vor ihm die zahlung
ist kein alter mann aber die
erinnerungen aus seiner jugend scheinen
unfassbar weit weg
wir standen überall häuser 10 20 häuser
dicht bebaut hier spielten die kinder
da drüben war die schule dahinter haben
sie fußball hatten
es war einmal heute
versuchen wie zahm und die anderen
dorfbewohner zu retten was zu retten ist
wir haben einen bambus zaun gebaut einen
stein wall aufgeschüttet und mangroven
gepflanzt auf 16.000 quadratmetern aber
wir wollen das noch ausdehnen
es ist mühsam ein steiniger weg die
mittel sind bescheiden der gegner
übermächtig
wir machen das wie die natur mein armes
terrasse der apk feld ab und steckte am
boden nur wenn die wellen kommen und die
pflanzen noch nicht verwurzelt sind wird
alles weggespült wenn wir hundert
tausend mangroven pflanzen schaffen dass
am ende nur ein paar hundert aber wir
haben keine andere wahl wir geben nicht
auf wenn wir aufgeben dann ist die bald
alles weg
die leute sind arm und das ist ihre
heimat einfach woanders neu anzufangen
keine option
der aufwand lohnt sich früher mussten
wir alle ein bis drei jahre unsere
häuser aufgeben umziehen weg vom wasser
jetzt nur alle zehn bis zwölf jahre das
liegt an den schutzmaßnahmen dem damm
den mangroven sonst wären wir ständig
auf der flucht vor dem meer
thailand im klimawandel keine abstrakte
vorstellung
realität unwetter überschwemmungen das
gab es immer aber aus vielen
landesteilen werden doch immer häufiger
extreme wetterlagen gemeldet
auch die hauptstadt und
millionenmetropole bangkok ist betroffen
manchen gelingt es daraus ein erlebnis
zu machen das restaurant am großen fluss
serviert im hochwasser munter weiter die
gäste haben ihren spaß vor allem wenn
alle paar minuten ein schiff vorbeikommt
wellen macht
anderswo ist den menschen nicht zum
lachen gerade die armen viertel bangkoks
werden wieder und wieder überflutet der
boden sinkt das wasser steigt was nicht
schwimmt läuft an ein schwimmendes haus
könnte eine alternative sein unter dem
gebäude liegt ein riesiges luftkissen
steigt der wasserpegel hebt sich das
haus eine ausbaufähige idee meint der
architekt
wir haben auf der erde doch schon
riesige dinge die schwimmen können
kreuzfahrtschiffe oder öltanker viele
von denen sind um einiges größer und
schwerer als ein haus stellen wir uns
ein kreuzfahrtschiff doch einfach mal
als einen auf der seite liegenden
wolkenkratzer vor wenn der schwimmt dann
kann fast jede form der architektur
schwimmen
das modellhaus jedoch findet noch keine
abnehmer zu teuer sagen viele und uns
wird schon nicht treffen oder nicht noch
einmal menschliches kalkül
dabei macht sich doch überall auf der
welt die erkenntnis breit dass der
klimawandel unnachgiebig ist dass die
zeit drängt es kommt was auf uns zu wir
müssen handeln
am tempel empfehlen sie dennoch
buddhistische gelassenheit der
wunschpunsch ihn neu zu errichten etwas
höher etwas leichter aber doch im
angesicht des meeres erscheint manchem
kurzsichtig da mag der up noch nicht mal
widersprechen aber nah und
ich mache mir keine sorgen über ihre
zukunft ich liebe ihn jetzt ich kann
nicht sagen ob der tempel irgendwann
wegziehen muss oder nicht
keiner weiß was die zukunft bringt ich
werde das vielleicht gar nicht mehr
miterleben da muss ich dann der nächste
ab drum kümmern das ist eine frage der
zukunft ich muss nur die fragen dieses
moments beantworten
so mag der tempel kuntz armut schien
zwar nun auf einer insel liegen doch es
ist eben eine insel der glückseligkeit
umspült vom meer aber bewacht vom buddha
was soll schon passieren